he's banned too I think we'll go ahead
and get started hello and welcome to
left bank books for our event with Carol
Anderson this is of course not a left
bank book sorry
I'm Shane Mullen the events host for
left bank books and I would like to
thank our co-sponsor for the evening the
Ferguson Public Library their work and
their activism is incredible and
inspiring they are a wonderful partner
to have for such an event like this left
bank books hosts over 300 author events
each year and it is with your help that
we were able to continue bringing in
your favorite authors when you support
us you are reinvesting in your community
because your tax dollars are going into
your schools parks streets libraries and
community projects and an incredibly
higher rate we give back to our
community by partnering with many
charities and organizations and also we
are doing our summer fundraising for our
River City readers program we have
brochures at the back we the River City
readers serves st. Louis public school
children by building their own home
library and encouraging literacy the
students get to keep five books each
year and meet the authors of culturally
relevant new books I would like to ask
you to make a donation tonight of any
amount you can do so at the sales table
or you can ask me about sponsoring a
child this program is near and dear to
my heart and it is wonderful and I will
tell you all about it if you would like
to hear so I would like to especially
thank all of you for your continued
support for us left-bank books for
information about our upcoming events
information on our reading group
Ferguson reeds and much more please
visit our website left-bank comm grab
one of our newsletters at the back and
definitely get signed up our email
mailing list and now I am very proud to
introduce Carol Anderson for left-bank
books as Ferguson erupted in 2014 and
media commentators across the spectrum
referred to the angry response of
African Americans as black rage anderson
wrote a remarkable op-ed in The
Washington Post
showing that this was instead
white rage at work carefully linking
historical flashpoints when social
progress for african-americans was
countered by deliberate and cleverly
crafted opposition white rage pulls back
the veil that has long covered actions
made in the name of protecting democracy
Jelani Cobb author of the substance of
Hope says few historians write with the
grace clarity an intellectual Verve that
Carol Anderson summons in this book
there are a handful of writers whose
work I consider indispensable professor
Anderson is high up on that list and the
editor of white rage also says that this
is one of the most important books that
he has worked on Carol Anderson is
professor of African American Studies at
Emory University she is the author of
many books including bourgeois radicals
the n-double-a-cp and the struggle for
colonial liberty liberation 1941 to 1960
and numerous articles Anderson's opinion
article from the Washington Post will
appear in the fire this time a new
generation speaks about race edited by
National Book Award winner Jasmine Ward
which comes out in August and I highly
recommend that book as well that article
shaped and helped define this book and a
movement white rage is inspiring
maddening and necessary from the
epilogue imagine it is time to diffuse
the power of white rage it is time to
finally truly move into the future
tonight Carol Carol we will be
discussing white rage the unspoken truth
of our racial divide answering your
questions and signing copies of her book
available for purchase from left-bank
books would you please help me in
welcoming Carol Anderson
[Applause]
and thank you thank you for coming out
on a what day is this and I really truly
appreciate it and I appreciate what
Ferguson Public Library has done and is
for this community thank you and I
appreciate left-bank books as well thank
you I wanted to spend some time first
kind of talking about how I got to white
rage what white rage is and then to move
into several excerpts from the book and
then open it up for Q&A when I first
began to wrestle with the concept of
white rage wasn't Ferguson it was in
fact in February 1999 when a black man
in New York City stepped out on his
doorstep after a long hard day's work to
go get something to eat and he was
greeted with 41 bullets 19 of which hit
him
his name was amadou diallo and he was
gunned down by the NYPD amadou diallo
was unarmed that was bad enough but as
we know from from these killings it is
the response that begins to tell you
what is happening in society and so I'm
sitting there and I'm listening to Mayor
Rudy Giuliani in an interview with Ted
Koppel on Nightline and Ted Koppel is
talking about the NYPD the amadou diallo
killing he's talking about 41 bullets
he's talking about stop and frisk he's
talking about police brutality and Rudy
Giuliani says
I have the most restrained and best
behaved police force you can imagine
okay yeah I had one of those Scooby Doo
moments and and then he began to talk
about how his policies were working that
what he has put in place in New York
City has brought down crime New York
City is a safer place because of his
policies and he has you know flow charts
and graphs and bars everything and what
you don't hear is that an unarmed black
man stepped out on his porch and was
gunned down I'm sitting there going
something is fundamentally wrong
structurally wrong I didn't know what to
call it I didn't know what to label it
but I knew something was going on and I
you know continued as a professor began
working and thinking and working and
thinking and and and then August 2014
the television is on and I'm watching
and i see ferguson in flames and then I
hear the pundits talking and what they
were talking about was black rage why
are black people burning up where they
live what is wrong with black people how
could they burn up where they live well
you know there's something wrong with
black people and why are they burning up
we're in and it didn't matter what
ideological stripe it was all centered
the baseline the starting point was
black rage and I found myself in this
moment shaking my head you know that
moment when you're shaking your head
something's going on and you don't even
realize you're going that's not right
that's not right and that's when it hit
me that I said no what we're really
seeing is white rage
what we're really seeing is that we have
been so focused in on the flames we have
missed the kindling we have missed what
has stoked this fire we have missed for
instance the disfranchisement of the
black community in Ferguson that had
through all kinds of shenanigans and and
rigmarole had created we're in the 2013
municipal election in a population that
a 67% of Ferguson's population you had a
6% black voter turnout you got to work
really hard to make that happen
we missed in Ferguson schools that have
been on probation for 15 years 15 years
where a state has an accounting system
of a basically accreditation of 140
points and Ferguson public schools were
getting 10 points a year and we have
allowed that to happen for 15 years we
have allowed an entire generation of
students to go through from kindergarten
to graduation with a school in a school
system that we know doesn't work
kindling we have a police force that
didn't see that its role was to protect
and serve but saw african-americans as a
revenue generating source that could
provide 25 percent of the city's budget
kindling
and what all of this kindling does I and
as I started wrestling with white rage
and began to understand that what we're
really looking at are the policies as a
nation we are so drawn to the
spectacular we are so drawn to what we
can see that we miss those tectonic
plates that are actually moving white
rage moves subtly almost imperceptibly
corrosive ly through the courts
legislatures government bureaucracies
through the White House through Congress
and it wreaks havoc subtly imperceptibly
so that you it's hard to discern what is
the source of what you're seeing and so
I set out to make white rage visible
because the first thing you got to do is
you got to be able to see this thing
the trigger for white rage is black
advancement
it is not the mere presence of black
people that is the catalyst for white
rage but it is blackness with ambition
blackness with Drive with purpose with
aspirations with demands for full and
equal citizenship
it is blackness that refuses to accept
subjugation blackness that refuses to
give up and through a formidable array
of policy assaults and legal maneuvering
white rage consistently punishes black
resilience and black resolve how else
can we reasonably explain why government
after government fought so hard to keep
black children from getting an education
we saw it after the Civil War we saw it
all the way through the brown decision
we see it now why is it so difficult
Hren
why do we have this even when at least
since 1957 and Sputnik when the US said
oh we have a national security crisis we
must educate as many of our citizens as
we can to be able to effectively wage
the Cold War but Brown was not going to
get implemented so even in the face of a
national security crisis even in the
face when we say this is what our nation
needs white rage says I don't think so
or why with this nation designed a war
on drugs dart incarcerates most those
who sell and do drugs the least why and
why particularly after the triumphs and
the successes of the civil rights
movement with the Civil Rights Act of
1964 and the Voting Rights Act of 1965
why would we incarcerate communities why
would we overwhelm state budgets why
would we destabilize families
why would we do this to those who aren't
the primary users and sellers of
narcotics why why would state after
state develop rules after ruse to keep
American citizens from being able to
vote and to have a say in their own
democracy why when we say we value
democracy when we say this is why we
fight then why would we have such mass
voter suppression and understand that
none of this was done with a mere Klan
cross right there weren't any cross
burnings that just made all of this
happen all of this was done coolly
methodically systematically and so in my
new book white rage I trace this
historical pattern with signpost
reconstruction the great migration the
brown decision the civil rights movement
and the election of Barack Obama and I
also trace it through three key sectors
education the criminal justice system
and the right to vote and so now I want
to read some excerpts
so as you know in 1954 the US Supreme
Court ruled that separate but equal was
unconstitutional overturn the Plessy
decision and said that we must integrate
Jim Crow was no longer the law of the
land the south rose up and said with
massive resistances that uh and used a
series of roses that in fact dragged
this process out for a long long time
well in 1973 the battle the court
battles are still going on in 1973 there
was an area in San Antonio called the
Edgewood district and in the Edgewood
neighborhood it was 96 percent
mexican-american and african-american it
was the poorest neighborhood in San
Antonio with the lowest median income
and the lowest property values they
taxed themselves at the highest rate in
order to try to fund their children's
education by taxing themselves at the
highest rate they garnered $21 per
capita
meanwhile Alamo Heights which was a
predominantly white neighborhood in San
Antonio tax themselves at a much lower
rate they garnered over $300 per student
lower rate 1500 percent more in funding
now what we know is that property values
have a lot to do with public policy
where governments choose say to put the
landfill where they choose to put the
highway where they choose to zone
certain types of businesses and not
others has a lot to do with property
values so the parents and the Edgewood
district took Texas to court and said
this violates our children's Fourteenth
Amendment rights to have equal
protection under the law it violates
brown the US Supreme Court ruled in a
5-4 decision four of the justices were
appointed by Richard Nixon and one was
appointed by Eisenhower Dwight
Eisenhower that quote there is no
fundamental right to education in the
Constitution
they said that the state's funding
scheme did not systematically
discriminate against all poor people in
Texas and that because districts across
the United States used property taxes
that this method was not so irrational
as to be invidiously discriminatory
Thurgood Marshall this his dissent and
that's what I'm going to read fully
recognizing the implications of
Rodriguez the name of the case Justice
Thurgood Marshall was apoplectic more
than 40 percent of black children 14 and
under lived with families below the
poverty line as compared with about 10%
of white children under those
circumstances Marshall feared
african-american children wouldn't stand
a chance the decision he wrote in his in
his dissent could only be seen as a
retreat from a commitment to equality of
educational opportunity as well as an
unsupportable capitulation to a system
which deprives children of the chance to
reach their full potential as citizens
he was simply dumbfounded that the
majority would acknowledge the existence
of widely disparate funding for schools
across Texas but then instead of
focusing on the cause of that disparity
clumsily pirouette to all of the states
opposed efforts to close the gaps the
issue Marshall explained is not whether
Texas is doing its best to ameliorate
the worst features of a discriminatory
scheme but rather whether the scheme
itself is in fact unconstitutionally
discriminatory moreover he found at the
height of absurdity that Texas could
actually argue that there was no
correlation between funding and school
quality
you can't make this up and then from
that faulty premise deduce that there
were no discriminatory consequences for
the children of the disadvantaged
districts he was equally unimpressed
with Texas tendency to parade before the
justice the stories of children who had
excelled despite living in
under-resourced districts as some sort
of proof that funding was irrelevant
that a child could excel even when
forced to attend an underfunded school
with poor physical facilities less
experienced teachers larger classes and
a number of other deficits compared to
the to a school with substantially more
funds marshal Bart is to the credit of
the child not the state but Rodriguez
placed the onus solely on the backs of
the most vulnerable while walling off
access to the necessary resources for
quality education and played beautifully
into the colorblind post-civil rights
language of substituting economics for
race yet achieving a similar result the
simple truth was that by virtue of the
sheer demographics of poverty Rodriguez
would have not only a disparate impact
on african-american children but also a
disastrous one
I know sobering
and I then move into the war on drugs
because it has so warped American
society in ways that are so profound and
so I walk us through how the war on
drugs emerged I then walk us through the
court cases the Supreme Court decisions
that Michelle Alexander in the new Jim
Crow so beautifully laid out and then I
began to lay out some of those
consequences and so as I go through the
court cases I then say taken together
those rulings allowed indeed encouraged
the criminal justice system to run
racially amok and that's exactly what
happened on July 23rd 1999 in Tulia
Texas in the dead of night
local police launched a massive raid and
busted a major cocaine trafficking ring
at least that's how it was billed by the
local media which after being tipped off
lined up to get the best most
humiliating photographs of 46 of the
town's 5,000 residents handcuffed in
pajamas underwear and uncombed bed hair
paraded into the jail for booking the
local newspaper the - Lea Sentinel ran
the headline - Lea streets cleared of
garbage
the editorial praised law enforcement
for reading - of drug-dealing scumbags
the raid was the result of an 18-month
investigation by a man who would be
named by Texas Attorney General as
outstanding lawman of the year attached
to the federally funded Panhandle
Regional Narcotics Task Force based in
amarillo about 50 miles away from to lea
Tom Coleman didn't lead a team of
investigators
instead he single-handedly identified
each member of this massive
cocaine operation and made more than 100
undercover drug purchases he was held as
a hero and his testimony immediately led
to 36 38 of the 46 being convicted with
the other cases just waiting to get into
the clogged court system Joe Moore a pig
farmer was sentenced to 99 years for
selling $200 worth of cocaine to the
undercover narcotics agent
Kizzy white received 25 years while her
husband William cash loved land at four
hundred and thirty four years for
possessing an ounce of cocaine well the
case began to unravel however when Kizzy
sister Tanya went to trial
Coleman swore that she had sold him
drugs
Tanya however had video proof that she
was at a bank in Oklahoma City 300 miles
away cashing a check at the very moment
he claimed to have bought cocaine from
her then another defendant Billy Don
wafer had time sheets and his boss's
eyewitness testimony that wafer was at
work and not out selling drugs to
Copeland and when the outstanding lawman
of the year swore under oath that he had
purchased cocaine from Ewell Bryant a
tall bushy-haired man only to have
Bryant balled in five feet six appear in
court it finally became very clear that
something was awry Coleman in fact had
no proof what so ever that any of the
alleged drug deals had taken place there
were no audio tapes no photographs no
witnesses no other police officers
present no fingerprints but he is on the
bags of drugs no records
over the span of an 18-month
investigation he never wore a wire now
he claimed to have written each drug
transaction on his leg but to have
washed away the evidence when he
showered so I'm either thinking he
showered once in 18 months additional
investigation led to no corroborating
proof when the police arrested those 46
people and vigorously searched their
homes and possessions no drugs were
found nor were weapons money
paraphernalia or any other indication at
all that the housewife pig farmer or
anyone else arrested were actually drug
kingpins what was discovered however was
judicial misconduct running rampant in
the war on drugs in Tulia Texas with a
clear racial bias Coleman had accused
10% of to Lea's black population of
dealing in cocaine based on his word
alone 50% of all of the black men in the
town were indicted convicted and
sentenced to prison
Randy Creta Co of the William Moses
counselor fund for racial justice called
Tulia a mass lynching taken down 50% of
the male black adult population like
that it's outrageous it's like being
accused of raping someone in Indiana in
the 1930s you didn't do it but it
doesn't matter because a bunch of
Klansmen on the jury are going to string
you up anyway but this wasn't 1930 it
was the beginning of the 21st century
and a powerful civil rights movement had
bridged those two eras
and then the last excerpt I want to read
the last chapter deals with the election
of President Obama and how white Rage
reared up in really deep profound ways
almost in ways that we hadn't seen in
years and so as I walk through voter
suppression and then I move into the
threats on his life and the disrespect
that the office of the president
received I then began to deal with the
violence black respectability or
appropriate behavior doesn't seem to
matter if anything black achievement
black aspiration and black success are
construed as direct threats Obama's
presidency made that clear aspirations
and their achievement provide no
protection not even to the god-fearing
on June 17th 2015
South Carolinian Dylan roof a white
unemployed 21 year old high school
dropout was on a mission to take his
country back ever since George Zimmerman
had walked out of the courthouse a free
man after killing Trayvon Martin and a
racially polarized nation debated the
verdict roof had looked to understand
the history of America trolling through
the internet he stumbled across the
Council of conservative citizens try see
the progeny of the 1950s white Citizens
Council that had terrorized black people
closed schools and worked hand-in-hand
with state governments to defy federal
civil rights laws but described but
despite the group's avowed racist belief
system in the mid to late 1990s as the
Southern Poverty Law Center
reports the group boasted of having 34
members who were in the Mississippi
legislature and had powerful Republican
Party allies including then Senate
Majority Leader Trent Lott of
Mississippi by 2004 Mississippi Governor
Haley Barbour the chair of the
Republican National Committee and 37
other powerful politicians had all
attended tri-c events in the 21st
century Earl Holt the chair of the tri-c
gave $65,000 to Republican campaign
funds in recent years including
donations to the 2016 presidential
campaigns of Rand Paul Rick Santorum and
Ted Cruz the traicee then enjoyed
precisely the cachet of respectability
that racism requires to achieve its own
goals within American society and its
website of hatred and lies provided the
self-serving education Dylan roof so
desperately craved
he drank in the poison of its message
got into his car drove to Charleston
entered Emanuel AME Church and landed in
a Bible study with a group of
african-americans who were the very
model of respectability roof prayed with
them read the Bible with them thought
they were so nice then he shot them dead
leaving just one woman alive so that she
could tell the world what he had done
and why you're taking over our country
he said and he knew this to be true well
not even a full month after Dylan roof
gunned down nine African Americans at
Emanuel AME in Charleston South Carolina
Republican presidential frontrunner
Donald Trump fired up his silent
majority audience of thousands in July
2015
with a McCobb promise don't worry we'll
take our country back
no it's time instead that we take our
country forward into the future thank
you thank you and now I'm going to open
it up for questions but I would ask
because c-span is filming this that if
you have a question to please go to the
mic ask ask yes thank you
okay well I have read your book okay and
we've discussed it with Ferguson Book
Group here
readings on race book group my one
question that I and I found it very
helpful and very a good compendium of
things that are kind of no but it's good
to have it all in one one one place the
one concern I had was it seemed that you
really detailed problems that happen
under Republican administrations you
went the Eisenhower to Nixon
you know the bush and then the present
situation under Obama but you didn't
talk much about say what say for example
Clinton's ending welfare as we know it
or other things that might happen under
Democratic administrations which also
had disproportionate effects on black
people absolutely and thank you and one
of those one of the reasons behind that
is because I was looking at these
moments of advancement and in those
moments of advancement where you're
seeing the pushback comes you know
before 68 from the you know you've got
the Republicans and you got the
Democrats but one of the things I in a
piece that I did in salon just recently
I do begin to unpack just some what Bill
Clinton and what he has done now the the
article focused in on the GOP but
understand that they're they're a couple
of things happening here is that white
rage moves through parties it it isn't
just isolated like in the Republicans
are isolated in the Democrats and that
is also really important to understand
yes so it was just the kind of epochs
there that I that I looked at that did
that but I could have easily for
instance during the Great Depression
when Franklin Delano Roosevelt is
creating a whole series of programs one
of the things that you see happening
there are that the Southern Democrats
are saying oh yes we really do need
relief we need relief we need
agricultural funding and support we need
Social Security but black people can't
have that so you can create this whole
new deal compendium of programs but you
have to exclude African Americans and I
could I could have talked about that but
this crunch piece of time I I really
just want to thank you so much for this
work it's it's incredibly profound and
the things in here that you cited that I
was completely unaware of like that the
state of Mississippi didn't ratify the
13th amendment until 2013 yes the state
of Mississippi finally got around to
ratifying the 13th amendment which
abolished slavery in 2013 they said it
was an oversight well so you know the
other they're really difficult pieces in
here I wanted to thank you for telling
the story of which I had only recently
learned about but but I think being a
witness to her story is so important and
so powerful so I read the book for the
Ferguson readings on race book love to
and and so you know I was really
diligent about reading it and I had to I
had to put it down sometimes and it was
so difficult and painful so my question
for you is was it like that for you
writing it I mean it had to be mmm so
much more difficult to ride it in
research
it was tough one of the things that I
bet I've been through this this this
before in the first book eyes off the
prize I had to deal with a lot of the
lynchings that happened after the Second
World War you know so I'm dealing with a
blowtorch lynching where and you know
and they're talking about his blood
boiling so hard that his eyeballs popped
out of his head you know so and I'm in
those records I'm I'm reading through
this so I've been in the bowels and so
that's how it felt in these moments
going through this but one of the things
so I have the Mary the the Mary Turner
lynching is just it is it is tough and
it is a woman who protested because her
husband was lynched and she's angry
she's eight months pregnant and and so
the lynchers come after her because she
didn't know her place how dare she
protest that her husband was lynched and
so they snatched her they stripped her
they hung her upside down from a tree
doused her with gasoline and set her on
fire and then they saw her stomach
because she's eight months pregnant
they saw her stomach quivering and so
they got a knife and they just sliced it
right open the baby pops out and then
they stomped on the baby's head and when
you're reading through those records
because one of the things that I think
is also important to understand about
the way right white rage works is that
we focus in on this kind of violence but
it is the system around that condones
and legitimizes that violence that
allows it to happen that allows it to
occur that sanctions it that's what
gives it traction so everybody knew who
killed Mary Turner
you go through the n-double-a-cp spay
purrs as Walter wife ahead of the
n-double a-c-p is writing to the
governor of Georgia and he's naming the
names so and so and he works at Standard
Oil so and so and he works at the
furniture shop so and so and he dun Dada
da Dada and nothing happened and so when
you have that kind of violence that
happens in a community and then the
powers that be are like yes that's white
rage because it creates the kinds of
policies the kinds of judicial systems
that allow that to occur to in order to
keep African Americans in their place to
stop that advancement yeah thank you so
I have another question a question you
know and we talk about this a lot in our
book club but what can we do what can we
do you're doing it you know and this is
the thing about I study movements
I love movements I my might I love what
is what I study or how do we change a
norm
there are these moments so for instance
before the Civil War eighty percent of
the nation's GNP was tied up in slavery
tied to slavery eighty percent of the
United States GNP tied to slavery but we
got to the point we had to fight a mean
hard war but where the norm changed
where we knew that slavery was wrong we
came to know that Jim Crow was wrong we
came to know that apartheid
wrong the movements that it takes to
change those norms it's bit by bit its
neighbors talking to neighbors its
mobilizing its organizing its writing
it's talking it's thinking it's it's
voting it's voting it's laying pressure
on policymakers to make this a much more
just indecent nation and world that's
how we do it that's how we do it by
working together
okay I'm sorry I'm good even everybody
how you doing all right
I'm head right if the divers right you
think I want to say recently I was a
completing a job applicant job
application mm-hmm and under the
nationalities it listed Latin Spanish
Mexican hey listen
african-american is an african haitian
or north african they said asian is an
island pacific or japanese but just said
white under caucasian but nothing to
reference where european or Russian or
anything like that why do you think it's
so hard for some Caucasians to to
recognize that there are also immigrants
to this country and all and also quick
to say this is their country I think a
lot of that has to do with the way that
history is taught a through 12 it
creates a civics lesson and not a
history lesson
it creates citizens in terms of a very
kind of flattened narrative about how
that who and how the nation by whom and
how the nation was founded who built the
nation who created the railroads who who
built the cities who who invented this
who invented that and if you go through
those kinds of standard textbooks what
you will find is very minimal discussion
about anybody else that it is White's
who have built America whites who have
sustained America White's who created
America whites are America
and it's that framing in our textbooks
from K through 12 that have really
solidified this narrative and so we do
get what we're a nation of immigrants
you know you get that kind of thrown out
there but then we have you know the
melting pot and we all become one but
not really and so when you begin and I
think I saw a statistic that said only
about 20% of Americans have a bachelor's
degree so that means somewhere around
about 80 percent that this is the
history that they know this is the
history that they know and you know how
it is when somebody tells you something
the first story you hear is the one then
that everything else has to be weighed
against so if the first story you hear
and it's the story you have heard over
and over and over and over again then
trying to to to say hey you know your
folks came over from Poland can tell you
a quick story I have tons of stories I
was teaching a u.s. Cold War foreign
policy class and I broke my students up
into research teams and they were to be
the president's transition team for a
series of issues so we had things like
human rights and energy the environment
and I had one on immigration and so that
team actually wrote a great policy paper
on immigration really good policy paper
on immigration but I require that they
then presented to the rest of the class
as part of the president's team
the responses were so vitriolic things
like well yeah so you know my parents
were immigrants but I really do think we
need to build the wall Wow Wow Wow
that's how it happens
yes so you talked about that we only pay
attention to the flash points right here
in Ferguson Michael Brown is shot and
killed sorry you talked about the fact
that people only pay attention to the
flash points here in Ferguson Michael
Brown is shot and killed people take to
the streets the police the politicians
the governor overreact
Ferguson blows up and suddenly it is
national and international news right in
Baltimore people march peacefully and
then nobody pays attention until people
start looting and rioting and suddenly
once again it is national and
international news so my question is as
somebody who is about as nonviolent as
you can get right like how it seems like
the only thing that people pay attention
to the only thing that white people pay
attention to is when suddenly things
once again turn violent so how do you
protest peacefully and still get
attention and make a difference when it
seems like the flashpoints are the only
thing that that people will listen to
one of the reasons I wrote white rage is
so that we begin to pay attention to the
kindling that we really understand the
power of policy that we begin to pay
attention to our office holders and what
they are recommending or doing and
asking that next set of questions and I
would push back just a bit on that
White's only pay attention to when
something blows up because in movement
in struggle you have whites who are
there on the ground who are doing that
hard heavy lifting
you have Asians who are on the ground
doing that hard heavy lifting as well as
having Latinos and having
african-americans you have people who
are doing the the the base work the
organizing the strategizing the letter
writing and social media has helped so
much with that kind of mobilization so
you have that going on the thing that
happens then is though is that we don't
see it but it is happening and that is
why when something jumps off mad crazy
because that kind of organizing has
already been in place you have people
and organizations that step into the
breach
who help provide policy rationales
policy options who provide safe spaces
we just don't see that heavy lifting
initially but it is there and that's why
we have to keep at it keep doing it it's
not sexy we love sexy and and this kind
of heavy lifting isn't sexy but as I
document it's tried to go through just
looking at what the Supreme Court is
doing this is why we have to pay
attention to who the Supreme Court
nominees are we have to pay really close
attention because their decisions help
shape the wharf and wooof of this nation
to follow up with his question I think
we really do pay attention we whites but
in a different way so let's go back to
Charleston and you know one of the
things I noticed which I always see when
one of us whites don't act appropriate
as White's do then the media starts
talking about well was it parents was an
environment and we go on to this an
intellectual assessment so we can figure
it out so we can keep our image intact
while we never grieve the death of eight
a nine of our brothers and sisters but
they're African Americans so it doesn't
count
you know we charge ourselves by our best
example and we judge you by your worst
and so there's violence in that by us
never allowing ourselves we call it oh
it's not safe no it's not uncomfortable
but we don't know we must label it so
the media then presents in a narrative
that we whites want and endorse and
support and that's violence for me I I
think it is fine we know flashpoints
when we're stepping out of line we make
sure we come back looking good could you
comment on there okay that was a yeah I
I'm working on a piece right now dealing
with the politics of respectability and
one of the elements in this politics of
respectability is how african-americans
don't get the benefit of the doubt and I
but I walk through I mean to say I walk
through why the politics of
respectability was deployed during the
civil rights movement as a means to try
to humanize african-americans to the
larger American society to the power
brokers and to white citizens because
there had been a series of killings
brutal horrific killings like the the
lynching of Claude Neill in 1934 where
he was dragged out of an Alabama Jail
sent through a gauntlet of torture down
into Florida it was a spectacle lynching
hoisted up on a stand and tortured with
tortured and the Florida said what
there's no crime here because he wasn't
from here Alabama said he would there
was no crime here because he wasn't
killed here and if so the N double ACP
turns to the FBI because now we have the
Lindbergh kidnapping law that if you
cross state lines it's a federal offense
and J Edgar Hoover said well there was
no ransom required no crime and so
seeing what this kind of violence on the
black body has done
you saw the civil rights movement deploy
the politics of respectability as a way
to make visible that the only way the
only reason that you're seeing mrs.
Amelia Boynton
yanked onto the concrete in
in Selma it's because she's black
this can't be anything but racism you
know so it was a way to say you can't
say I'm gonna add a criminal record and
so this is why you see this deployed the
politics of respectability does have
some good pieces in it I'm not one of
those who just plops it off as some kind
of bourgeois Victorian thing because
being sober is not a bad thing we know
that alcohol and drugs destroys families
being sober is not a bad thing
education is a good thing you know so
they're these ones but what it doesn't
do is to protect black bodies from white
violence and so I look at one of the
things about Charleston Charleston drove
me to this because I looked at that
because the nine who were killed were
the model of respectability and you saw
nikki Haley and South Carolina going oh
that was really bad that was really bad
then you had to have their killer so you
got respectability box one their killer
had to be an avowed white supremacist
they had to find incontrovertible proof
that he was an avowed white supremacist
so he had to have the Rhodesian flag the
apartheid South Africa flag and he had
to have the Confederate flag I'm not
done yet just like and then he had to
have his manifesto where he says I want
to start a race war but that's still not
enough
then you had to have the families of the
slain forgive Dylan roof Wow Wow
and then they are going to take down the
Confederate flag with dignity we see it
today what happened in Orlando is
horrific but the way that the killer has
then become the avatar for all Muslims
in the world but you didn't see the same
kind of rationale being used for
instance with Timothy McVeigh right and
so that's part of the way that these
narratives work and the way that they
begin to undergird policy because you
hear as they're talking about Muslims
and terrorists that they're in fact
talking about what kind of policies to
put in place
based on this yeah yes another thing
Bree Newsome you know that story when
they looked up and they saw three
flights flying at half-mast was the US
flag a half mass was a state flag and
the Confederacy flag flew at full mass
yes and then it strategized and she then
was going up the pole and a white male
talk I stood at the bottom and the order
was given by the police to taser which
would have electrocuted her then they
stopped they looked at the white man
this is my interpretation kill white man
to kill her no they backed off and let
her live the only reason I think she's
alive today is because that white man
was at the base of that thing saying he
grabbed the pole and so then he told him
to kill him and they wouldn't kill him
to kill her people don't know that stir
because they won't report it it's I'm a
historian you need use so I'm going to
run with this one um in 1946 in Columbia
Tennessee a white shop owner smacked a
black woman her son a black veteran was
standing next to her you do not lay your
hands on somebody's mother that veteran
picked that white man up and went and
threw him out the complete glass window
whites in the town organized to lynch
the the black man the black veterans in
that town weren't having it and
basically it's called the Columbia
Tennessee race riot after it was over 23
he was 23 african-americans were
arrested for murder no White's were
arrested although as you know lots of
shooting and killing happened Thurgood
Marshall came to
defend the black man in Columbia
Tennessee but he couldn't stay in a
hotel there because there were whites
only hotels so he after court every day
he would have to drive and so Thurgood
Marshall had one of his colleagues was a
white man as they're driving out of
Columbia Tennessee one night two after
court he looks behind and there's a cop
car behind him they go left the cop car
goes left they go right the cop car goes
right they speed up the cop car speeds
up finally the cops pull him over and
they're like you need to come with us
third goes like ha snap Thurgood gets up
he gets in the cop car the white man
looks up and he realizes that there are
several cars behind that cop car and
they don't turn around to go back into
Columbia Tennessee but instead they're
heading off into the woods Thurgood
Marshall is getting ready to get lynched
the white man hops over onto the
driver's seat turns that car on and he
starts following and he's scared but
he's like I'm not going to let this
happen
they speed up he speeds up they turn
right he turns right they turn left he
turns left and he's going and finally
they stopped and they get off the car
like what are you doing and he says I'm
not gonna let you do this now I think
about the courage that it took in 1946
in the middle of Tennessee this lone
white man standing up before the sheriff
and his posse saying I'm not going to
let you do this and it was one of those
moments I'm so glad I've got some some
folks my age up in here remember those
old Aqua Velva commercials Thanks
it was like this bracing moment from
they had never seen anything like this
before
and they went okay fine yeah yeah so
there is history in this kind of
solidarity it's absolutely essential yes
hi you got it hey that's half the battle
ask you about is I'm a believer that you
know the problem with the Reta I'm
involved on a lot of groups you know
concerning racism and its overthrow or
South solving it getting rid of it but I
think we have a problem I think we
really need to know more about really
what happened and we have not been told
the real truth you know it may offend my
Caucasian friends but I'm sorry I think
we they need to be offended if the truth
is going to offend them it'll help them
become whole and I think that's really
one of the problems is that we are not
really telling the truth and I'm glad
that you and Michelle Alexander or
writing the
writing and a lot of things are coming
out as an example I heard I listen to
Sirius satellite radio which I enjoy and
I hear a hunter miss hunter and she
always talks from a historical point of
view and she was talking about something
you hit up on the lynchings that took
place and I didn't know they had
lynching parties yes they had yes they
would they would roast yes animals and
then they would bring the person in to
be lynched they would not only elect him
they would cut off their head and they
might barbeque it they wouldn't eat it
they were throw it away so things like
that we really need to know more about
and and the thing she brought up about
the they're saying that the 49 people
that were killed in Orlando was a
divorce
you know mascara that we've ever had and
she said Karen hunter said no that's not
true and you look at Evelyn I think I'm
calling right someplace in Arkansas
505 Elaine Arkansas any st. Louis or
Andrew Tulsa so I say keep on writing in
I wouldn't ask you another question
I've been looking for some books by E
Franklin Frazier I read about him in the
late 50s and early 60s a great social
theoretician and I would like to know
where I might retrieve some of those old
books and and the book she mentioned and
I don't remember the author's name about
the lynchings that took place but a lot
of these books are out of print now so
if you could kind of help me if you
don't do it now I'll do it after yes
yeah yeah because there are some really
good books that I use in my class on
lynching because most of my students
have not heard about this but one of the
things that happens for instance in many
black families there's a lynching story
you know and you begin to think about
what that means to have a lynching story
in the family how it it shapes the way
you move through this society how it
frames what you think about justice and
how the system works in this society it
is it is staggering and so one of them
there are several books that I use and
one of them is Philip Dre at the hands
of persons unknown okay that sounded
like time anyone else okay well thank
you so much
I really appreciated this thank you